bei der gegenständlichen waffe handelt
es sich unter stimmten 77 2 com andere
dass van gerwen 25 und den sondereinsatz
verbänden im einsatz steht es stellt
derzeit die am weitesten entwickelte
version bestellbar
es hat hier ein neues wissen mit
erhöhter optik damit die reichweite
erhöht werden kann darüber hinaus ein
rausch punkt visier das schielen auf
kurze distanzen erleichtern zusätzlich
können hier weitere anbaugeräte angebaut
werden
wir haben hier ebenfalls eingebaut 140
mm kanada welches verschiedenste
munitions worten von ein stoff beginnend
über beleuchtung und genetische munition
verschießen kann